todo
[Música]
hola hoy en science click la entropía y
la flecha del tiempo
consideremos las dos imágenes siguientes
la primera representa una estructura
precisa una manzana la segunda no tiene
estructura es homogénea
imaginemos ahora que generamos una
tercera imagen eligiendo al azar el
color de cada pixel
una vez generada la imagen la comparamos
con las dos anteriores
a cuál de estas dos imágenes se parece
más la nueva
visualmente la imagen aleatoria se
asemeja más a la imagen número 2
homogénea
ninguna de las dos tiene una estructura
concreta a diferencia de la manzana
si seguimos generando nuevas imágenes al
azar la mayoría de ellas se parecerán a
la imagen número 2
la probabilidad de crear al azar la
imagen de una manzana es muy baja en
general obtendremos más bien una imagen
desordenada sin mayor estructura
es esta propiedad de asemejarse algo
aleatorio lo que llamamos entropía
aquí la imagen número 2 tiene más
entropía ya que se aparenta más a una
imagen aleatoria
[Música]
en nuestro universo la entropía se
define de la misma forma el universo
está formado por átomos que pueden
disponerse de muchas maneras algunas de
estas disposiciones parecen homogéneas
mientras que otras tienen estructuras
si generamos al azar una nueva
disposición eligiendo la posición en la
velocidad de cada átomo es más probable
crear una disposición homogénea que se
asemeje a un gas en lugar de una manzana
o un cubo de hielo
decimos que un gas tiene más entropía ya
que se le asemeja más a una distribución
aleatoria
en concreto la entropía de un objeto es
un número que cuenta entre todas las
configuraciones posibles las que más se
asemejan a nuestro objeto la idea es que
a nuestra escala la falta de precisión
de nuestras medidas y el gran número de
átomos nos impiden ver las diferencias
entre estas configuraciones todas
parecen idénticas aunque técnicamente
son diferentes a escala microscópica
para entenderlo mejor echemos un vistazo
a estas dos imágenes
cuando las miramos de cerca podemos
distinguir el color de cada pixel y por
lo tanto es posible diferenciar una de
la otra pero si miramos desde lejos los
detalles precisos de cada imagen ya no
son visibles y las imágenes parecen
ahora idénticas
volviendo a la física la entropía del
cubo de hielo es así menor que la del
gas ya que muchas más configuraciones se
asemejan a gas en lugar del cubo de
hielo
en cierto modo la entropía mide el grado
de libertad que tienen los átomos nos
dice si nuestro objeto requiere una
configuración precisa o si puede
fluctuar a través de muchas
configuraciones manteniendo la misma
apariencia
[Música]
en un sistema de baja entropía las
moléculas de agua no tienen mucha
libertad solo tienen acceso a muy pocas
configuraciones precisas y su agitación
es muy débil lo que explica que el cubo
de hielo esté frío por el contrario en
un sistema de alta entropía las
moléculas son mucho más libres y pueden
fluctuar a través de muchas
configuraciones diferentes están muy
agitadas de ahí la alta temperatura
intuitivamente la noción de entropía nos
permite entre otras cosas caracterizar
los estados de la materia sólido líquido
o gas
cuando hervimos el agua por ejemplo la
energía que le proporcionamos nos
permite aumentar su entropía es decir
liberar las moléculas que la componen
darles un comportamiento más aleatorio
desordenado y así pasar una fase de
mayor entropía el vapor
la noción de entropía es muy útil en
física y en química en particular para
caracterizar los estados de la materia
sin embargo como hemos visto con el
ejemplo de las imágenes la noción es
mucho más fundamental y puede extenderse
a una multitud de otros ámbitos
en matemáticas la entropía ya no mide la
cantidad de información que contiene un
objeto como por ejemplo un texto un
texto repetitivo contiene poca
información ya que basta con identificar
la fórmula que se repite para
describirlo completamente
un texto más aleatorio menos
estructurado contiene mucha información
ya que la única forma posible de
describirlo es indicar cada carácter uno
por uno
en informática la entropía algorítmica
es bastante similar y mide la
complejidad para que un ordenador genere
un objeto específico
cuanta más información contenga el
objeto menos se podrá comprimir el
código que lo escribe
la idea de entropía se utiliza incluso
en el estudio de la biodiversidad ya que
nos permite cuantificar el rango de
variaciones dentro de un conjunto de
elementos
también es útil en el estudio de los
sistemas caóticos para caracterizar su
comportamiento imprevisible aleatorio
como por ejemplo el que a largo plazo un
péndulo doble puede haberse afectado por
una pequeña perturbación
por último el estudio de los agujeros
negros nos permite asignar a estas
entidades una entropía que mide la
cantidad de información que han
capturado la entropía de un agujero
negro se distribuye por su superficie y
cuanto más información capture más
grande se hace el agujero negro
finalmente la entropía desempeña un
papel crucial en nuestra comprensión del
tiempo y más concretamente de la
dirección en la que se producen las
transformaciones
para entenderlo imaginemos las dos
configuraciones siguientes
por un lado un globo está abierto dentro
de una caja y el globo contiene un gas a
alta presión
por otro lado imaginemos el mismo globo
abierto pero esta vez el gas está
distribuido uniformemente dentro de la
caja
[Música]
suponiendo que la caja evolucione
espontáneamente se puede adivinar el
orden cronológico en que se producen
estas dos situaciones
fue el gas primero comprimido en el
globo y luego expulsado con el tiempo o
por el contrario estuvo el gas
inicialmente homogéneo y luego
comprimido en el globo
intuitivamente nuestra experiencia
cotidiana nos dice que el gas ha
escapado el globo que tendería a
disiparse en lugar de volver
espontáneamente al interior en general
tenemos la intuición de que los sistemas
físicos tienen a homogeneizarse con el
tiempo que las tensiones como la presión
en el balón tienden a relajarse
si ponemos un objeto caliente en
contacto un objeto frío esperamos por
ejemplo que sus temperaturas se
equilibren gradualmente
sin embargo a escala microscópica los
dos estados no parecen tener una
diferencia fundamental es difícil
entender por qué el fenómeno ocurriría
necesariamente en una dirección
es en este punto donde la noción de
entropía es crucial
hemos visto anteriormente que la
entropía de un objeto es mayor cuando el
objeto parece homogéneo
por lo tanto el segundo estado tiene una
mayor entropía que el primero y es
precisamente por esta razón que el
proceso se produce en esta dirección y
no en la otra
cuando dejamos con sistema evolucione
espontáneamente su entropía tiende a
aumentar haciendo que el sistema sea
cada vez más homogéneo
con el tiempo la entropía de un sistema
aislado siempre tiende a crecer
pero detrás de este fuerte principio se
esconde en realidad una explicación
sencilla y lógica
para entenderlo volvamos a nuestra
analogía del principio ante nosotros una
imagen estructurada que representa una
manzana
a cada instante imaginemos que hacemos
que el color de cada pixel de la imagen
fluctúa ligeramente de forma aleatoria y
observemos su evolución en el tiempo
a escala microscópica la imagen fluctúa
y gradualmente se aleja de su
configuración inicial a medida que
transcurre el tiempo a través eran
múltiples configuraciones diferentes
pasando aleatoriamente de una a otra
pero a nuestra escala la imagen de la
manzana parece desvanecerse gradualmente
se vuelve cada vez más homogénea hasta
parecerse totalmente la imagen gris que
hemos visto al principio
fluctuando al azar poco a poco la propia
imagen se ha vuelto cada vez más
aleatoria y como vimos al principio del
vídeo una imagen cuyos píxeles son
aleatorios tiene una probabilidad muy
alta de ser homogénea
en nuestro universo este fenómeno es
similar los átomos agitan y su
distribución microscópica fluctúa
constantemente pasando espontáneamente
de una configuración a otra si esperamos
el tiempo suficiente la estructura del
universo tiende cada vez más a ser
aleatoria y una estructura aleatoria
tiene casi siempre a ser homogéneo
[Música]
a medida que pasa el tiempo las
estructuras de nuestro universo tienden
a borrarse mientras que su entropía
total sigue aumentando
la entropía del universo mide la
progresión de su homogeneización a lo
largo del tiempo
para concluir la entropía es un concepto
fascinante aunque es muy concreto ya que
nos permite caracterizar los estados de
la materia y sus transformaciones se
reduce finalmente ideas muy simples en
particular la entropía explica la flecha
del tiempo la dirección en la que
evoluciona el universo mediante una
simple lógica probabilística
los átomos pueden estar configurados de
muchas maneras diferentes pero desde
nuestro punto de vista algunas de estas
configuraciones parecen iguales y en
particular las más homogéneas como hay
más de ellas al fluctuar poco a poco el
universo tiende naturalmente a
adoptarlas a largo plazo
[Música]
hoy en día se plantea la cuestión es el
universo acabará siendo completamente
homogéneo en efecto se podría imaginar
que al aumentar constantemente su
entropía acabaría por alcanzar un máximo
que el universo llegaría a un punto de
equilibrio y que la flecha del tiempo
desaparecería ya que sólo quedarían las
fluctuaciones microscópicas
sin embargo el universo se está
expandiendo y los fenómenos de
relatividad general ligados a su
geometría estructural pueden quizás
evitarle este panorama de muerte térmica
[Música]